>>> BREAKING OVERNIGHT, WE
LEARNED THE WYOMING REPUBLICAN
PARTY, ITS CENTRAL COMMITTEE,
VOTED TO NO LONGER CONSIDER
CONGRESSWOMAN LIZ CHENEY A
MEMBER OF THE PARTY.
THE DECISION ALL STEMS FROM
CHENEY'S EFFORTS TO HOLD DONALD
TRUMP ACCOUNTABLE IN HIS ROLE IN
THE INSURRECTION JANUARY 6th.
THE VOTE WAS 31-29.
JOINING ME NOW, "NEW YORK TIMES"
WASHINGTON CORRESPONDENT AND CNN
POLITICAL ANALYST MAGGIE
HABERMAN.
TALKING ABOUT LIZ CHENEY.
STEP BACK, LIZ CHENEY, DAUGHTER
OF DICK CHENEY, BUT IN HER OWN
RIGHT, A CONSERVATIVE STALWART,
THROWN OUT OF THE PARTY BECAUSE
SHE WON'T STAND BY ONE PERSON.
>> LOOK, WHEN THE ARGUMENT BY
KEVIN McCARTHY WAS THAT YOU
CAN'T HAVE A LEADER IN
MEMBERSHIP AGAINST A LEADER IN
MEMBERSHIP, IT'S MORE, YOU'RE
NOT WITH DONALD TRUMP.
IT WAS SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
THE MORE YOU SEE THIS SPREAD
THROUGH THE PARTY, THE HARDER IT
IS GOING TO BE FOR ANYONE TRYING
TO CHALLENGE TRUMP IN ANY WAY
GOING FORWARD.
>> IT'S NOT DEMOCRACY, SMALL
"D," ONE POLITICS, ONE MAN.
NOT SOMETHING YOU SEE IN THE
U.S.
>> THIS IS NOT HOW THE TWO-PARTY
SYSTEM WORKS.
IT IS NOT PLEDGING LOYALTY TO
ONE PERSON.
I THOUGHT THE VOTE WOULD BE
WORSE THAN IT WAS.
>> 31-29 SHOWS A NEAR MAJORITY
OF REPUBLICANS IN THE STATE
WILLING TO SAY, THIS IS STUPID.
>> I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO ACTUALLY ARE WILLING,
CERTAINLY PRIVATELY, I'VE TALKED
TO THEM, YOU'VE TALKED TO THEM,
WHO WILL SAY, "THIS IS A
MISTAKE.
THIS ISN'T THE ROAD THEY SHOULD
GO DOWN."
FEWER ARE WILLING TO PUT THEIR
NAMES ON IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF THIS WAS A
SECRET BALLOT, BUT THE FACT
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN NUMBERS
WILLING TO OPPOSE THIS, IT
SPEAKS TO SOMETHING WE ARE
SEEING.
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN THE PARTY
WHO ARE UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THIS
DRIFT TOWARD SUPPORTING THIS ONE
PERSON OVER EVERYTHING ELSE.
>> I WANT TO COME BACK TO THAT
IN A SECOND BECAUSE I WANT TO
HIT WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH STEVE
BANNON FIRST.
ARRAIGNED ON CHARGES OF CONTEMPT
OF CONGRESS.
HE CAME OUT AFTERWARDS AND SAID,
THIS IS BASICALLY THE BEST THING
THAT EVER HAPPENED TO ME.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> THIS IS GOING TO BE THE
MISDEMEANOR FROM HELL FOR
MERRICK GARLAND, NANCY PELOSI,
AND JOE BIDEN.
ADMINISTRATIVE STATE WANTS TO
TAKE ME ON, BRING IT.
WE'RE HERE TO FIGHT THIS, AND
WE'RE GOING TO GO ON OFFENSE.
YOU STAND BY.
>> OKAY.
A, WHAT IS HE DOING HERE?
>> SO HE'S CLEARLY HAVING THE
TIME OF HIS LIFE, TO SOME
EXTENT, TURNING THIS INTO A
CIRCUS, RIGHT?
TURNING THIS INTO SOME EFFORT TO
BE A MARTYR.
NORMALLY, YOU DON'T SEE A
DEFENDANT SAY THINGS LIKE THAT
AFTER AN ARRAIGNMENT.
YOU SEE THE LAWYER TALK, AND IT
IS MORE RESTRAINED.
HIS LAWYER HAS BEEN TALKING, BUT
BANNON IS USING THIS TO
GALVANIZE SUPPORT FOR BANNON, AS
HE OFTEN DOES.
>> DAVID SCHOEN WILL BE ON THE
SHOW LATER TALKING TO BRIANNA.
I UNDERSTAND YOU HAVE REPORTING
ON WHOSE IDEA IT WAS TO GET
HIM -- AND HE WAS ONE OF TRUMP'S
IMPEACHMENT LAWYERS IN FEBRUARY,
SECOND IMPEACHMENT LAWYERS.
WHOSE IDEA WAS IT TO GET HIM
CONNECTED TO BANNON?
>> I DON'T KNOW WHOSE IDEA IT
WAS.
I HAVE REPORTING THAT TRUMP
ASKED SCHOEN TO GET INVOLVED IN
THIS, AND SCHOEN SAID YES.
SCHOEN, WHO DID TRUMP'S
IMPEACHMENT, THE SECOND ONE,
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IF
TRUMP HAD NOT WANTED HIM TO.
TRUMP IS, YOU KNOW, GIVING HIM
THIS NUDGE AND ASKING HIM TO
TAKE THE CASE, TELLING YOU WHERE
TRUMP IS IN TERMS OF BANNON.
TRUMP OVER FOUR YEARS HAS BEEN
ALL OVER THE MAP ON STEVE
BANNON.
RECENTLY, HE'S TURNED INTO A
SUPPORTER OF HIS, AS BANNON HAS
BEEN MORE VOCALLY SUPPORTIVE OF
TRUMP.
AND SO I THINK THAT IS WHAT
YOU'RE SEEING.
WHAT IT MEANS FOR THE PRIVILEGE
FIGHT, I DON'T THINK WE CAN TAKE
A GUESS AT THAT.
I DO THINK PEOPLE READ INTO
THAT.
>> HOW MUCH TIME WE GOT?
I WANT TO KNOW IF I CAN PLAY THE
FULL -- OKAY.
CHRIS CHRISTIE, I WANT TO PLAY A
LITTLE SOUND OF CHRIS CHRISTIE
TALKING TO DANA BASH LAST NIGHT.
DID A SPECIAL ABOUT CHRIS
CHRISTIE, WHAT HE IS THINKING,
WILL HE RUN, WOULD HE TAKE ON
TRUMP.
PLAY A LITTLE SOUND FROM THAT.
>> WITH ALL DUE RESPECT, THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A COP-OUT.
>> I'M SURE YOU THINK IT IS A
COP-OUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
I ALSO KNOW THERE'S NO REASON TO
CREATE TUMULT IN A PARTY THAT
ALREADY HAS A LOT OF TUMULT IN
IT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THE QUESTION THERE WAS, WOULD HE
TAKE ON DONALD TRUMP IF TRUMP
RAN FOR PRESIDENT.
HE DODGES THE QUESTION.
WHAT IS MOST INTERESTING TO ME
ABOUT CHRIS CHRISTIE ISN'T ABOUT
CHRISTIE HIMSELF.
IT'S THE IDEA THAT HE IS
WILLING, TO AN EXTENT, TO
DIRECTLY CRITICIZE DONALD TRUMP.
IT MAKES ME WONDER NOW WHETHER
SOMETHING HAS CHANGED OVER THE
LAST FEW WEEKS, WHERE THERE ARE
SERIOUS REPUBLICANS -- SAY WHAT
YOU WANT ABOUT CHRIS CHRISTIE,
BUT HE IS A SERIOUS
REPUBLICAN -- WHO THINK THERE IS
AN AVENUE TO TAKE HIM ON.
>> MAYBE NOT DIRECTLY FOR
THEMSELVES IN TERMS OF RUNNING,
BUT AT LEAST TO CONFRONT WHAT HE
HAS BEEN SAYING AND WHAT HE
REPRESENTS IN TERMS OF THE PARTY
GOING FORWARD.
I INTERVIEWED CHRIS CHRISTIE
RECENTLY AS WELL.
HE MADE SOME VERY SIMILAR
POINTS.
WHAT HE DID SAY TO ME WAS THE
VICTORY IN VIRGINIA BY GLENN
YOUNGKIN AND THE FACT THAT NEW
JERSEY'S GUBERNATORIAL RACE WAS
AS CLOSE AS IT WAS, THOSE ARE
TWO BLUE STATES -- NOT ENTIRELY
THE SAME BUT THEY'RE STILL BLUE
STATES -- SHOWS YOU THERE IS
SOME WINDOW FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO TALK ABOUT ISSUES AS OPPOSED
TO TALKING ABOUT DONALD TRUMP
AND THE THINGS DONALD TRUMP
WANTS TO TALK ABOUT.
THAT WAS VERY MUCH WHERE HE WAS
SPEAKING.
>> IF IT IS JUST CHRIS CHRISTIE,
THAT'S ONE THING.
IF IT IS CHRISTIE AND SOMEONE
ELSE, THEN SOMEONE ELSE, IT'S
ANOTHER.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> AS THEY PERCEIVE JOE BIDEN,
WHOSE APPROVAL RATING IS NOT
GOOD RIGHT NOW, PERHAPS TO BE
WEAKENED, IT MAKES ME WONDER IF
THEY THINK THEY DON'T NEED
DONALD TRUMP.
IF THAT'S A HASSLE THEY MAY NOT
NEED OR WANT TO DEAL WITH GOING
FORWARD IN 2024.
>> WE'RE A WAYS AWAY FROM VOTERS
GETTING TO THAT POINT, BUT I DO
THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO REMAIN VERY TIRED AND
EXHAUSTED BY THE TRUMP YEARS.
AMONG REPUBLICANS, NOT
NECESSARILY TRUMP'S HARDEST CORE
BASE.
LOOK, BEING OFF TWITTER HAS BEEN
A BLESSING FOR TRUMP.
IT MEANS HIS STATEMENTS ARE NOT
IN EVERYBODY'S FACE ALL THE
TIME, AND THEY GET TO TELL
THEMSELVES IT'S NOT REALLY THAT
BAD.
YOU AND I CAN GET HIS STATEMENTS
AND KNOW WHAT HE IS SAYING, AND
IT IS THE SAME WHEN HE WAS ON
TWITTER.
THE MORE PEOPLE GET A REMINDER
OF TRUMP AND HIS CONDUCT, I
THINK YOU WI